this week has been an emotional roller
coaster
how did you carry over the momentum from
an explosive game four
game five and then put everything else
aside that happened this week and go out
and drop
50 in a must win game tonight
gotta win a win
he shoots me a lot with all the
excuse me a lot take a deep deep breath
jamal
you were outstanding tonight we
understand that these are tough times
jamal what what are you thinking about
right now
[Applause]
i just want to win
and in life you find things that hold
value i think it's a fight for
but we found something we're fighting
for as nba as a collective unit
and i usually choose that uh as a
similar to me to keep fighting
all around the world
so i can say they give me a lot of power
to keep fighting we want to win
i show my motion it comes out so
you have a picture of george floyd on
your right shoe here we've got bjana
taylor
[Music]
why why is this been so personal for you
jamal
because it's not just in america it
happens everywhere
and uh crosstalk is coming together nba
and you know it doesn't take one meeting
it takes a couple meetings a few
meetings
takes phone calls takes persistence
it's not gonna take one night and we've
been doing it trying to fight for 400
years
but these shoes give me life even though
these people are gone
they give me life they give me they help
me find strength
to keep fighting this world that's what
i keep doing
you're a special person jabal murray on
and off the court congratulations